the Joe Rogan experience I'm excited to
talk to you I'm super excited to talk to
you about several subjects but this one
thank you very much for this first
edition copy of your area 51 an
uncensored history of America's top
secret military base book I'm super
excited about this I heard through the
grapevine you're a fan I'm a freak when
it comes to this stuff do you what do
you think is going on up there I mean
same thing that's going on all over the
place when it comes to military secrets
which is stuff that you want to know
about very few people know about and
every now and then a journalist gets a
hint mmhmm yeah
do you think there's any alien stuff up
there I write in the book all about the
yeah yeah well tell them last twelve
pages you want me to well what do you
think so area 51 was this secret test
base where the CIA was running a spy
plane programs right so interestingly my
new book is about ground branch guys on
the ground
that's about air branch mm-hmm what we
were doing in the air and it was this
idea that we should spy on the enemy
okay and but if you go back in time why
area 51 really started you learn that it
was a base hidden inside of a base
nuclear weapons and it was all about
beating Stalin at his black propaganda
campaign as I write in the book hmm to
hoax Americans in a war of the worlds'
type scenario whereby little men who
looked like aliens would get out of an
aircraft and the government would go
crazy about it and then Stalin would say
look we have not only do we have
technology but better than you but we
have a better propaganda department than
you rule that Joe you gotta read the
whole book this is like a this is a
tough opening you got me losing stuff a
lot but it's a good spot all right it's
good spy it so Stalin just hired short
people
what would he do all right I'm gonna
make you save that I'm gonna make you
earn yeah I mean you want me to talk
about that right now right
why is it I'm sweaty gonna get to it
we're gonna get to surprise kill vanish
as well I want to just yeah why does it
make you sweat oh my god it's such an
incendiary topic
I mean people people want to believe
they're aliens right right okay I mean
I've spent five books dealing with the
mythology of area 51 which is phenomenal
in its own way because it speaks so much
to power to morality to information to
you know people's desire to know what's
going on and and the government's desire
to keep things hidden so this topic is
always coming up because a lot of people
want to believe that there were aliens
in that craft and my source who I write
about in the book told me otherwise that
they were genetically you know that they
let me stop you right there because when
you say that craft what you mean is the
supposed UFO records it crashed in
Roswell New Mexico in 1947 that's what
you mean right but that was never
supposedly taken to area 51 was supposed
to be taken to wright-patterson Air
Force Base the legend has it that Truman
flew there to meet them and right that's
one legend yeah so in my book I
interview a man who worked for the
Atomic Energy Commission who tells a
different story
tells the story of receiving that craft
at area 51 in 1951 which is why the base
is called
area 51 oh and that inside the craft
were humans who had been altered
surgically altered to look like aliens
in a plan for Stalin to sort of twist
Truman's arm because at that time we had
the atomic bomb when Roswell happened we
had the atomic bomb and the Soviets did
not be there when you say humans that
were surgically altered to look like
aliens do you mean so this is 1951 so
you're talking about four years after
the supposed crash yes so what was the
Mahdi's they kept the body the capitol
bodies in one formaldehyde
but yes and also because the idea was
and remember or I can't say remember
because you haven't read the book yet
right and I wrote this book eight years
ago hmm but it did really impact a lot
of my a lot of my thinking and working
on on you know government secrecy
projects because it makes you really
consider what a hoax means and what it
means to a population of people and how
the government begins to work with
disinformation versus cover stories and
all of that but going back to answer
your question that is what I was told by
the source that but how reliable is this
source this is a very incendiary idea to
rely upon one individual's recollection
of it which is why the book went through
the roof in terms of people being upset
about it I mean were they oh my god I
interviewed 79 CIA guys Air Force guys
spy pilots engineers I mean who's mad at
you the conspiracy theorists were mad at
me because they said this woman is
bananas they were aliens well even if
they weren't aliens right there's also
there's accounts that it was some sort
of a test vehicle and that there were
actually just dummies inside their crash
test dummies that they used there's been
a bunch of different versions of it but
the most compelling version of the area
of 51 alien myth to me as Bob Lazar did
you get into that yeah he plays a huge
role in area 51
I mean before Bob Lazar went public no
one even knew about area 51 people
people knew people it was it was common
folklore but there was no definitive
proof that there was something going on
over there other than some weird VHS
footage of things flying around the
desert that seemed to be behaving in a
way that modern aircrafts are not
totally capable of at least modern
piloted aircrafts are not totally
capable I mean which brings me to
another book I wrote called the
Pentagon's brain which you know sort of
off this idea was like wait a minute
what kind of technology is the
government capable of anyway we have a
whole department for that reason called
DARPA which looks at weapons
systems 25 years out so the idea that
you and I don't know what the military
is capable of in the air under water
wherever it may be is because we're not
thinking 25 years out and they are and
they're developing weapon systems the
great weapon systems of the future
that's what they call them right look
how they develop the stealth bomber
Lincoln that was all out in the area 51
and groom Lake